hello everyone I hope we're still having
a great Saturday and do I feel silly I
was actually waiting for the second
round of London chess classic to start
not even realizing that today was a rest
day and this didn't really occur to me
as you know you played one round how do
you get a rest day that's you know okay
I mean I'm glad they have a rest day but
it's it's kind of a usual thing that
after a rest day there are fireworks all
over the board so let's hope for some
fireworks in round two and but until
that happens tomorrow I decided to show
a game from round one Hikaru Nakamura
and Nakamura versus Vishwanathan Anand a
lot of you have been requesting this
game and some of you said that uh
where's Nakamura we haven't chosen
shona Nakamura game in a while so here
it is it's a pretty feisty game both
players were out for blood so so let's
see it without further ado Nakamura has
the white pieces and he goes for 90 to
f3 Knight to f6 and g3 the Kings Indian
attack d5 the Yugoslav aeration and
Bishop to G to c5 nakamura castles d6 d4
seek after son d4 Knight chapters on d4
and Bishop to g7 knights to be three not
allowing key five with tempo Knight to
c6 and Knight to c3 g6 by Anand efore
and D for now and already here you can
see that Nakamura isn't interested in a
quick draw he plays Knight to a4 Knight
to b5 is a bit more often but if
nakamura wanted to do he could have
simplified the position with E 5 this
would result in something like D
captures on c3 and after the exchange of
Queens he captures on f6 Bishop captures
and after me captures and c3 Bishop
captures on c3 rope the d1 check King c7
and now rook to b1 getting out of the
attack of the bishop that's a pretty
simplified position maybe a bit more
favourable to black both players have
the bishop pair but black has to pawn
islands a White has three point island
so in the long run might be a bit more
favorable to black but nakamura isn't
interests
then the sea goes 492 a for honoured
castles and now c3 immediately
threatening either to capture on d4 or D
captures on c3 and tonight captures on
c3 getting denied Knight back into the
game closer to the center of the board
and E 5 by Anand Bishop to e3 and no one
wants to grab the Queen first to allow
the other player to to get a hold of the
open file with the rook Bishop to g4 now
f3 Bishop d7 and here we have nice to
see five and now we can see that Anand
as well isn't interested in simplifying
the position he wants that first point
in the first round he plays going to be
seven some of you probably even myself
might have considered a move like Bishop
to c8 controlling the movement of this
night on c5 but then this goes into
Queen captures rook captures and after
up to d1 exchanging a pair of rooks and
again you have a pretty simplified
position but Anand isn't interested he
gives up the bishop pair and plays Queen
to e7 Knight captures any six Queen
captures on e6 and Queen to d2 now Queen
to d2 seems like like a weird move you
know of course you're expecting the rook
to come to the open file why place a
queen on d2 but the truth is it doesn't
matter nakamura splain is to play Queen
to f2 so either way he could have played
Queen c2 Queen e2 or Queen d2 I don't
plays rook F to d8 and now Nakamura goes
Queen to f2 supporting the bishop
controlling d4 adding pressure to c5 and
also eyeing the a7 pawn kinda eater
forcing black to waste a move with a six
or this rook can't really move as it has
to protect the a 7-point tonight also
can't move it has to protect the a7 pawn
bishop to f8 by anand and we have h3 h4
was also possible perhaps Nakamura
doesn't want to commit he just wants to
wait and see what Ananse plan is Bishop
to b4 now and rook the c1 rock to d3
aaron is trying to get some activity
under d4
preparing rook a to the 8th but this has
to be countered rook after D 1 now
located the 8th of this does double up
the Brooks but wrote capture son d3 rook
after some d3 and Bishop to f1 now
kicking the rock back to his own ranks
Brooke the 8 and a 3 now aren't placed
Bishop to e7 you don't want to really
allow Nakamura to have two bishops while
you don't have either of the bishops but
Bishop captures on c3 was also possible
after rook captures something like a six
and the position is pretty close so the
bishop pair doesn't really have a chance
to shine just yet but in the long run
probably the bishops will be better
after a three Bishop to e7 by Anand and
g4 now came to g7 preparing to support
the H pawn when he pushes h6 came to H
to H 6 now and H for preparing g5 night
to d4 and Hiro Nakamura plays g5
immediately one other option was to go
for something like Bishop to h3 and
prepare g4 with a tempo but this this
would force black to push g5 himself but
after g5 and the 9th to e2 hikaru would
have threatened an IG 3 and then either
Knight f5 or Knight h5 but then of
course black would capture knife
characters and after Queen captures at
least you would get rid of the strong d4
Knight and you're still looking good
here threatening to capture on g5 and
after 98 it's a pretty double-edged
position but I'm sure Nakamura saw this
he just decided to go for g5 immediately
so g5 h characters on g5 h patterson g5
92 h7 and only now Bishop to h3 were the
tempo on the Queen Queen to b3 now and
this is why the previous variation
probably would have been better now now
the Queen um b3 is pretty active and
pretty dangerous f4
by Nakamura and Knight to c6
by playing Knight disease
Anand is now threatening to play F
capture he captures on f4 and then win
the g5 pawn and it doesn't help to
protect it if you play something like
rook to g1 to protect the g5 pawn after
capture still it captures on f4 Bishop
captures on f4 and now comes Bishop
captures on a3 still on and would win a
win a pawn after be captures Queen
captures on c3 and now now black is
definitely better in this position so
Nakamura decided not to protect the pawn
but to go for Knight to d5 activating
the knight on a beautiful d5 square this
is definitely worth the price of one
pawn he captures on f4 Bishop captures
on f4 and now Anand captures at Bishop
captures on g5 and on this upper pawn
Bishop g5 Knight captures on g5 and our
Queen to f6 check it's a pretty
dangerous position the black King has to
go to h6 he has to protect the night on
g5 so King to h6 pretty much only move
Bishop to g2 now Knight - h7 pressure to
g2 now of course the bishop is attacked
from the Queen and from the night here
so Bishop to g2 now guarding Age 3
nights to h7 would attempt on the Queen
forcing the Queen back and Queen
captures on f7 definitely definitely the
best move rook to f8 kicking the Queen
way and Queen to c7 now and here I got a
glimpse of this game in the life in the
live coverage by by a syringe in jihadi
Nakamura kinda had this idea of rook to
c3 and they said Nakamura missed this
but I don't think Nakamura missed this I
think he just didn't want to exchange
Queen's rook to c3 just kind of forces
the exchange of Queens if you don't want
to exchange Queens then if you play
something like Queen after some be too
rock to h3 elites to checkmate King g5
now rock g3 check and wherever the king
goes for example King edge for Queen
captures on edge so I'm gonna check mate
but after rock c3 the Queen's would get
exchanged and I think Nakamura wanted
the
to stand on the board so I have to work
to a faith Matt Mauro played Queen to c7
and uninflated Queen captures on b2
grabbing that pawn rook to h1 by
Nakamura and this is I think that this
rope to h1 is the reason why he decided
not to go for rook to c3 and this is
move 39 Queen to f2 by Anand and now
both players have to play one more move
to reach time control this is move 40
and it's very very important what you
play you know as I think Nakamura was
lower on time in this position so it's
definitely more important for him to
play the best move as he will get more
time on the clock after this one move
and probably Queen to g3 immediately is
the best option you know bringing the
Queen back to the defense but this next
move by Nakamura really made me laugh I
really I really enjoyed this Nakamura
instead of bringing the Queen to g3
immediately he played King to h3 and
this is classic Nakamura style I mean
it's a he's playing against former world
champion which honorton
on but still he gives him a chance to
blunder what's the idea here the idea is
if and this is move 44 Anand as well he
Anna still has to reach down control if
I don't win for something like Knight to
g5 check he runs into checkmate and the
checkmate escape the g4 and this
delivers checkmate so almost a check
made by the King Queen h4 blocking and
rook captures and h4 so this is a little
something Nakamura Nakamura went for of
course a nun didn't fall for this after
rook King to h3 I roped to f7 now
kicking the Queen away and now the Queen
isn't guarding g7 anymore
Queen to g3 now Nakamura brings the
Queen to g3 and here Queen the b2 was
played by aren't another option was
something like King to g7 and this would
actually allow aren't you know to
preserve his one-point advantage after
something like Queen captures rook
captures and rook to be won for example
b6 guarding the pawn
Anand is still upon
and you know he if he felt like it I'm
sure he would have gone for this I don't
think he missed a move like King to g7 I
just think he didn't feel like grinding
it anymore
so after Queen to g3 hadn't played Queen
to be - also maybe to preserve Queens on
the board maybe maybe he evaluated the
first position was slightly better 93 by
Nakamura now King to g4 doesn't do
anything at King G for King g7 your king
is just looking silly on g4 after Queen
B - 93 was played Knight to f6 now and
Bishop to f3 Bishop to f3 is the only
move that you know doesn't mess up the
game for Hikaru so Bishop to f3 is great
if you try something like roof erupt
rook to f1 you get rook to h7 and now
the White King is really in trouble
so after Knight f6 Bishop to f3 was
played King to h7 now here he Cara
played Knight to f5 and in this position
he offered the draw and the draw was
accepted by Anand neither player can
make any progress here of course you
can't capture then I capture the night
you get rope 2 h2 first kicking the
Queen away from the second rank and
threatening King to g2 for example if
you move the Queen something like Queen
e5 Kingi two leads to checkmate and that
has the block rook captures on h5 this
is checkmate
so after Knight to f5 of course this
doesn't work if it captures in row 2 h2
you have to capture the rook and after
Queen captures either King captures or
Queen captures black still has some
counter play but in the end probably
white Hikaru could win this so after
after this Knight to f5 move the players
agreed to a draw as any continuation for
example either you can play Knight to b5
to protect the g6 pawn but you really
don't have to after something like King
to h8
you can either give up the pawn and play
rook to h7 check after King moves rook
captures on h1 is a terrible move this
leads to checkmate
so you would have to go for something
like Queen to e5 check
and now after can you have to queen bee
to check King g3 queen bee 5 check king
of to queen bee to check and it's a
threefold repetition and neither player
can make any progress unless unless see
karo would decided to blunder so might
you know Anand could have gone for
something like this simply to allow his
card maybe play a move like king to e3
to try and avoid perpetual check then
Hikaru loses the game after Queen's III
check the king can no longer go back to
f2
if king f2 now comes Queen captures on
f3 would check a temporary Queen
sacrifice screen captures and Knight to
e5 forking the king and the Queen
winning the game so maybe it wasn't
necessary to accept the draw immediately
but you know you have a draw in the
first round against Nakamura why not
take it this did require some quite a
lot of calculation so yeah after Knight
f5 players agree to a draw and this game
amongst all other games ended in a draw
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and one fun story short story for the
end of this video I was contacted by the
creator of the video game called the
Black Death and he sent me an email and
he thanked me for promoting his video
game on YouTube and I was really baffled
by this I mean I I pretty much make
chest videos I don't promote any video
games what he did he probably just did a
quick search on YouTube videos
containing titles the Black Death and
then I realized what was going on I
emailed him back I told him I wasn't
promoting your game I was doing a video
on a use of henry blackburn one of the
greatest players of that era whom they
called the Black Death and he was like
oh sorry man but he still sent me some
beta testing keys and something if I
wanted to try out the game but either
way it's pretty cool that you know yours
of henry blackburn you know he did so
much for the chest community but even
today in 2017
he's promoting a video game so yeah I
would like to thank young no Hill and
Rafael Quintero Godinez for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon